here in Germany dozens of protests
against coronavirus restrictions took
place in several cities on Monday night
there were a large number of arrests in
the city of effort several police
officers were injured when they were
attacked with bottles and fireworks
the protests which for the most part are
illegal have become more militant in
recent weeks restrictions on public life
have been increased for those who are
not vaccinated Plans by Germany's new
government to introduce mandatory
vaccinations for certain workers have
further incensed the protesters
[Music]
so for more on this we're joined by
political correspondent Hans brunt from
our parliamentary Studio here in Berlin
Hans how significant are these protests
and do we know who the organizers are
well we have to say that it is a very
small minority in German society that
attends these protests and also a small
minority of people that are in fact
against vaccinations against these
restrictions but still they are very
loud they are very
noticeable and they do take place all
across the country they were really
dozens of protests last night ranging
from a couple of hundred people to a
couple of thousands in several cities
especially in Eastern Germany and they
have become more militant there have
been recent protests with torches that
were lit in front of the residences of
for instance the health minister in the
Eastern State of Saxony so some of the
politicians involved have been attacked
almost personally so the the anger
amongst these protesters seems to be
increasing in their preparedness to
become more militant to engage in
violence so given that what has the
government's reaction been to these
protests
well there has been an increase in
police controls in the past these
protests have been not prohibited but
the the attempt has been to allow them
to take place without any significant
incidents nowadays in various regions
there is an attempt actually to stop
them and to arrest more people
especially in the light of the fact that
right-wing extreme right-wing groups are
concretingly participating in this
encoding for violence there's also some
concern in government about the telegram
messenger Dean Messenger Service this is
a service that is used that has open
groups that are used for organizing
these protests mainly by the far right
wing or the right-wing populist
alternative for Germany party and
there's an attempt to try and control
these groups but the messenger messenger
service is based in in the Arab in the
United Arab Emirates and it's very
difficult actually to get hold of them
hence and thank you so much for that
update